The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Our guest today, this
is Neil Leonard from Berkeley.
As you can see by
your handout, he's
the director of the
interdisciplinary Arts
Institute there, and professor
of electronic production
and design.
He's been a friend of mine.
He was a former student,
briefly, at NEC,
and gone on to great,
wonderful things,
including travels
around the world,
as you can see by
the bio so we're
very fortunate that
he's here today.
He's got an assignment
on the handout which
he'll talk about
as we go through.
And that'll be due
next Monday like we've
done before with other
of our presenters.
Don't forget, Wednesday we
have a concert with Neil
and an associate
Robin Eubanks, who's
one of the great
improvisers on the scene
today, wonderful trombonist.
So they'll be in Killian Hall,
Wednesday night, 8 o'clock.
So bring everybody
you know for that.
It's free.
And once again, there will be a
concert reflection, as we know.
So turn it over to
Neil, welcome him.
Thank you.
NEIL LEONARD: Hi.
So I'm going to give a
short presentation on a work
I've created, a little
bit of background
and why I made the
work, and leave you
with an assignment,
which is to create
your own work along the
same lines and with the idea
that when I come
back next Monday
I'll be able to hear what
you guys have come up with.
And we could even play together.
So this is all kind of going
in the direction of you taking
some of these ideas and
running with them on your own.
I have a background
as a jazz saxophonist
with some activity in the area
of fine arts, which kind of
means that I've always had not
like a singular vision of what
I want to do, but
I've always kind of
been looking on the
peripheral for other things
that will be interesting.
When I was a teenager,
really, I played in bands
in Philadelphia.
And one of the bands
that I was part of
had these two brothers
Robin and Kevin Eubanks.
And Kevin Eubanks,
you might have known,
was the band director
of the Jay Leno Show
for I think about
18 years or so.
And he recently retired.
And his older brother, Robin,
is going to, as Mark said,
participate in the
concert on Wednesday
evening, fantastic
trombone player.
So he's a guy I've
known as a kind
of young musician
in Philadelphia.
And that was sort
of the background
I came from, just kind
of people playing jazz,
a little bit of pop musical,
a little bit of funk,
occasionally a Latin gig, as
a teenager in Philadelphia
before I moved out
of Philadelphia
to go to a conservatory.
In the course of
playing the saxophone,
I came across a few things
which really interest me.
One was a reel-to-reel
tape deck.
So the school I went to had
a small electronic music
studio with a EMS synthesizer
and a two reel-to-reel tape
decks.
And we were essentially
just shown this stuff
and invited to come
to use it somehow.
And at that time, I was really
interested in pop music.
That was kind of
before jazz, I had
listened to pop music that
had very interesting things
happening in the production.
So this would be Jimi
Hendrix, Pink Floyd,
you name it bands of say
the '70s, so to speak,
if I can really date myself.
And I began to teach
myself a little bit
about how to use this tape deck.
And one of the
first performances
I can remember doing was with
a trumpet player, my brother
Devin who played
trumpet, a pianist.
I played some objects
which I had just collected,
pieces of hardware,
chains, stuff like that.
I had some recordings
that I played back
from this reel-to-reel
tape deck.
And for me, this just
seemed like a normal way
that someone would
want to play music.
So you'd learn to
play your instrument.
You'd take lessons.
You'd be in ensembles.
You'd do all the things that
an instrumentalist would do.
But at least to
me, it just seemed
interesting to see
what else I could bring
to the mix of playing
improvised music.
And now a few decades
later, I'm really
still kind of doing that.
So I'd like to introduce
a work that I did that in.
But I guess first before
I show my own work,
I want to talk a
little bit about things
that were in the
air when I started,
a little more about things
that were in the air.
And two of the things that
I think had an impact on me
as a young musician, and
musicians in general,
was number one, John Cage.
And mark has
mentioned that you've
spoken a little bit about John
Cage's work in this class.
And did you talk
about Four Minutes
and 33 Seconds of
Silence by chance?
Do you know that work?
OK, so this is a work, seminal
work of 20th century music.
It's a piece in three parts.
And in the premier performance,
as I understand it,
the pianist went to
the concert hall,
opened up the lid
of the piano, sat
for four minutes and 33 seconds,
and then closed the piano lid.
And the piece was done.
I heard a really
interesting lecture on Cage
and his impact on today's
music in the last week.
And the person who gave
the talk pointed out
that Four Minutes and
33 Seconds of Silence
was not about listening
to the sound in the room.
But it was about
diverting your attention.
So you go to the concert
hall with the expectation
of seeing the lid
goes up on the piano,
this virtuoso plays
this incredible piece.
We're all in awe.
We applaud.
We go home.
And this piece was
like opening up
the door to shifting your
attention away from that.
And that has some really
interesting implications
because I think even for
Cage-- Cage was thinking
about the impact of
convention, but also
the impact of big
business on music.
So he wrote a lecture that
was called Lecture on Nothing.
And in this lecture, he talks
about the impact of media
culture, Time Magazine,
Life Magazine, Pepsi-Cola,
and how they have a bearing
on what we understand culture
to be.
I got a text for my son
during the last Superbowl.
And Rihanna was on.
And so I went to go catch
a little bit of this thing
he was all excited about.
And it was sponsored
by Pepsi, wasn't it?
Wasn't Rihanna's Superbowl
performance sponsored by Pepsi?
So, again, it was
like big business
is investing a lot of time,
money, and energy on what they
want us to see,
which is probably
going to lead us to
buy Pepsi-Cola, which
is why they're putting
money into this.
But all this is to say
that one of the things that
was interesting about Cage
was his music was encouraging,
or his work was encouraging
us, to look outside
of the prevailing
orthodox models of making
music, and thinking of other
ways to think about music,
to approach music, to
approach working with sound.
So somehow that stuck.
Another thing that was
in the air at the time
that I was starting to
play music was, I think,
one of the first albums--
I remember at one point,
for my birthday
and for Christmas,
all I wanted was recordings.
My mother's in the
back of the room.
So I remember giving her my
wish list, like, I want records.
And I remember one
of the recordings
I got for Christmas was
The Beatles White Album.
And The Beatles White
Album had a piece
called Revolution Number Nine.
Do anybody know that piece?
Raise your hand if
you know that piece.
And goes up, OK, good.
Two, OK, two people
know that piece.
John Lennon's wife,
Yoko Ono, no was
part of a group
called Fluxus artists.
And they were kind of
radical, experimental artists
who did all kinds of
really fascinating things
with performance, with music,
with film, kind of opening up
all genres and medium as
tools for them to explore.
And through Yoko Ono, John
Lennon knew John Cage.
And one of the things
he did upon becoming
in contact with John Cage
and these ideas is he
made this piece.
And I'd like to play just
a little bit of it that's
called Revolution Number Nine.
Now, I have colleagues who
say that this is a song
because John Lennon
only made songs.
So you could think
of this as a song.
I always sort of thought of as a
tape piece, or a sound collage,
because that's the kind of
terms I understand it in.
So let me see if I
can get this to play.
Can we turn this up?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NEIL LEONARD: I'm
going to stop it here.
The piece is eight
minutes and 22 seconds.
So it's a sizable piece from
this recording The White Album.
So somehow this
stuff was in the air.
And I think it really
had an impact on me.
As I was alluding to
earlier, did something
to my peripheral vision.
It made me think that there's
something interesting there
on the side to think
about and investigate.
With The Beatles it wasn't
just I Want To Hold Your Hand,
and these wonderful pop tunes
that I made, all of which
I really enjoyed.
But there was sort of
another world, other ways,
to think about
working with sound.
So what I would like to do
now is kind of fast forward
and show you fragments
of a piece I made,
a long piece I made,
in the past few years.
But before I do
that, I just want
to invite you, if you have
questions or comments, please
just blurt out your
questions or raise your hand.
And I'm happy to stop
anywhere along the way
and hear what's on your mind.
OK?
And actually, I
have a new tactic
which I'm using with my
students at Berkeley, which
is I don't let anybody leave the
room until they ask a question.
So that works pretty well.
Yes, you're leaving the room?
AUDIENCE: How did he make that?
Did he splice tapes together?
NEIL LEONARD: Splicing
tape together,
sometimes the
tapes are reversed.
It sounds like
snippets of a band
playing that were reversed.
They had a brilliant
producer who's
often referred to as the fifth
Beatle, George Martin, who
had a background in
orchestral writing.
So he had a very
robust skill set.
And if they came in
with an idea that
was kind of outside the norm
of making just pop hits,
or the way popular
music had been made,
he was often their collaborator
in going on a tangent
and doing things.
One example would be for
the piece Penny Lane.
I don't know if you
know that piece.
It's a fabulous song of theirs.
I think it was Paul McCartney
had seen the London Symphony
Orchestra.
He heard a Piccolo trumpet
in a Baroque concerto.
He went back and told
George Martin, like,
that was really cool.
And George Martin
said, oh, let's
get the Piccolo
player from the LSO.
And we'll use him on a piece.
So George Martin probably wrote
the part of the Piccolo trumpet
on Penny Lane.
And it doesn't sound like any
other track they ever made.
It's a wonderful,
idiosyncratic, playful track.
So, yeah, you get
to leave the room.
You asked a question.
I should give you a ticket.
So I'm going to fast forward.
And I spent a few years actually
working at Mass College of Art.
I thought it was going
to be a short-term job.
And it turned out to be an
eight year residency there and.
And I kind of went in
knowing a little bit
about computers, and
some teaching experience,
and a little bit of
administrative experience.
And they said, great,
you'll do all of that.
And I ended up staying
there because they
had a few really
interesting people who
came to work with us.
One was this jazz trombonist
named George Lois, who
is a seminal person working
with jazz and electronics, which
only fueled all this
curiosity even more.
John Cage was in town for a
year we did the Norton Lectures.
And he came to Mass
Art a few times
to meet with us, to
see what we were doing.
I got a chance to
show him my work.
There was a famous video
artist named Tony [? Allison ?]
who was on the faculty.
So all this is to say,
I ended up staying.
I really didn't think
I'd be staying there.
But I did.
I stayed there for
eight years, kind of
got involved once again in
working with visual artists.
Not so much me
making visual art,
but collaborating
with visual artists
on all kinds of projects,
performances, films, videos,
dance projects, theater
projects, happenings,
computer graphics with sound.
And then, eventually, I married
a woman who is a visual artist.
And we've done a lot of
work around the world.
We're doing a piece
in the upcoming Venice
Biennial in May.
We did piece in the
Havana Biennial last May.
And so I've kind of
worked quite a bit
with people who aren't
just playing saxophone,
or just play with saxophonists.
I've been very interested
in finding artists outside
of music to collaborate with.
So in this kind of journey of
working with artists outside
of music, I was at an Italian
estate on top of a mountain,
fantastic villa that
had two incredible view.
One is the marble
quarries of Carrara.
So across the valley, you can
see these mountains of Carrara.
And even though it's
summer and it's warm,
there's just white spilling
out of the mountains, which
is the fragments of marble
that didn't get schlepped away,
but are just kind of like
tumbling down the mountains.
So the mountains had these
sort of white residual marble,
chunks of marble.
The other side is
the Ligurian Sea.
And so my wife and
I were asked to make
a permanent installation
at this Italian estate.
And the owners,
every two years they
would go to the Venice
Biennial and pick an artist
to commission to make a
permanent, site-specific work
for their estate.
And we met them,
they'd say, hey,
would you do something
for our estate?
And we said, yep, we
got this great idea.
And they said, no, we don't
want to see your great idea.
We want you to come to the
estate, look at the place,
look at the territory,
and think of an idea that
would work for the space.
So its site specific, which
is a very important concept
in visual art.
So we developed a relationship
with this commissioner
of private sculptures for
this private sculpture park.
And one year I was going
back to visit them,
and they said, you know, we
have this sculpture which you've
seen that is this huge--
maybe you could draw it--
it's this huge pit that's
maybe eight feet across.
It's like a pit that goes
straight down the Earth.
And there's just a
spiral of church bells,
with no clappers in them.
Very large church bells, I
mean, they might be like,
from top to bottom, if
the hinge was up here,
the clapper would be down here.
They're very, very big.
But they're turned
upside down and they're
arranged in a spiral kind
of like facing the sky.
And so the owner said,
would you record these bells
and make something with this?
And I thought, well, I have no
idea what I'll make of this,
but why not?
I'll record these bells.
So I recorded the
sounds of these bells.
And I kind of had them around.
I started to play with
them, didn't really know
what I'd do with them.
And I met a choreographer,
also Italy, in Naples,
and then she asked me for a
composition for a dance piece.
And I thought, OK, well
I have these sounds
I made with these bells.
So maybe it would be
interesting to do something
with these belts.
So I'm going to play just a
fragment of this recording
that I made.
So you know when you
take a JPEG image
and you stretch it
horizontally, all of a sudden
the image is unrecognizable?
This is sort of what
I've done with sound.
And some of this I did
with some free software
which I could show you.
There's commercial software.
There's free software.
Lots of different software
does time stretching of audio.
So this could be
two seconds of audio
that's stretched
out for a minute.
The computer's going
to kind of sputter.
And then this is sounds of just
bells straight because I wanted
the listeners in the
dance performance
to be able to hear an actual
bell so this wash of sound
in the background would
make some kind of sense,
would have some context.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NEIL LEONARD: Now,
the dance performance
was 40 minutes long.
So it's a very
kind of slow, kind
of glacially moving performance.
So nothing in the music
happens too quickly.
The music goes through a
lot of different phases.
But each phase is
maybe five minutes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NEIL LEONARD: And this goes on.
But essentially, these
were recordings of bells
that I put in a program called
Spear, which we could look at.
And I began playing with ways
to time stretch the audio,
listening to what
sounded interesting,
throwing away a lot of stuff.
I kind of went into a phase
where when I make a piece,
I want to have a
phase in the beginning
where I call it sort of like
your work-- a research phase,
research, slash,
play, slash, failure.
Meaning, I take sounds,
I put them in a software.
I play around with them.
I research what I can do,
knowing that I probably
have time to throw
a lot of these away.
So I'm not doing this the
day before the performance.
This might be a few
weeks or a few months
before the performance.
And I want to build
in time to experiment,
knowing that a lot of the
experiments won't work.
So out of many of
those experiments,
I came out with this file.
Sent it to the dancer.
The dancer said, that's really
going to work for the idea
that she was thinking of.
And then she proposed a site
to do this performance, which
was Mount Vesuvius.
So Mount Vesuvius, as you
know, is the volcanic mountain
that erupted and buried Pompeii.
It is still an active volcano.
There are people who occupy the
side of the volcano pretty much
against, or in defiance of,
kind of zoning limitations
because the authorities
don't want people
to live in this volcano
because it's dangerous.
The people live there all
have gas masks in their house,
because the biggest
the problem is
the toxic gas that
comes from the volcano.
So in any case, there
was an art center
on the side of
this mountain where
we staged this performance.
And it kind of grounded
the whole piece right then,
because I begin to think of
what is it I'm working on?
I'm working with these bells.
We're doing something
on Mount Vesuvius.
How am I going to
begin to kind of focus
on an idea for this piece?
And there's an author
named Murray Schafer who
wrote a book called The
Tuning of the World, which
has been republished under
the title Soundscape.
You can find it on Amazon.
It's probably in the library
here, Murray H. Schafer.
And one of the things
he writes about
is that for any environment
there's a keynote sound.
There is a sound
that we human beings
associate with
every environment.
So with this
environment right now,
it's probably the sound of the
fan on the video projector,
or maybe the hiss coming
out of the speakers.
This would be
keynote sound here.
Perhaps in the
hallway, it's the sound
of footsteps within this space
that you know is very long.
It's not very wide.
And it's a fairly
reverberant space.
So every place you
go, there are sounds
that let you know
you're in that place.
When I was standing at
the subway the other day,
the metro in Brookline,
I was recording the sound
of the train because I've
taken that train, the D Line,
for ages.
And if I heard that
sound in my sleep,
I would know, Green Line,
lightrail vehicle, Green Line.
So I would say that
one of the things I'm
really interested
in doing is thinking
of pieces that have
a particular meaning,
have a meaning that's
tied to a particular site.
That fascinates me.
And that's a way to kind of get
out of doing what I always do.
So if I'm going to
work at Mount Vesuvius
I don't want to do just
what I do in Boston.
I want to do something
which is kind
of specific to a
performance which
is going to premiere
at Mount Vesuvius.
If I do something in
a rice paddy in Japan,
what's something about
a rice paddy in Japan
that I wouldn't
think of in Boston?
How can I respond to the
site where the work is?
So one of the ways
to respond to a site
where you're working
as a musician is
to think of the keynote
sounds, and play with those.
What are the sounds that are
typical to that environment
that kind of tell you
you're in that environment
that you can play with?
I should say, very briefly,
that one of the things which
is fascinating in Murray
Schafer's book and his ideas,
is that he also kind of points
to this way of reflecting
on your environment is an
integral part of literature
that we know, that we've
known for centuries.
So, for example, for Dickens
to talk about England
in the period of Oliver
Twist, cobblestone streets
have a particular sound,
horses on cobblestone streets
have a particular sound.
Those sounds are
sounds that Dickens
is very aware of being very
important to your understanding
of that place.
Those are parts
of Dickens' world.
Tolstoy, same, the example
I like most is Dante.
In Dante's Inferno, when Virgil
and Dante head off to hell,
they decide they're
going to go over to hell,
see what's over there.
They pass Cerberus.
They make it to
the mouth of hell.
There are no stars above hell.
The damned don't
get to have stars.
There's a black sky above hell.
And because the sky is
black and there's no light,
there are two paragraphs
of The Inferno
that the contact with
hell is an audio contact.
It's an audible contact.
They hear the sounds
of the damned.
And there is a two paragraph
description of the sighs,
and the gasping,
and the kind of toil
that these people are
experiencing in hell.
So all this is fascinating
to me because it
means that Dante, Tolstoy,
Dickens, were audio artists.
They were interested in oral
analysis, or oral reflection,
of their environment.
So this is part of
something we can do.
Our environment might be
like the vending machines
downstairs.
They may be the sound of
going up and down the hallway,
or going up and down
the staircases which
have wonderful echoes.
It could be the sound
of radiators just
kind of flapping.
But these are
sounds which can be
really interesting to work with.
So when I began to work
on this piece, which
I'm going to play not
the rest of, but more of,
I just wanted to say that
it occurred to me that there
was this wonderful opportunity
in that one of the most
incredible sounds ever in Italy
was Mount Vesuvius blowing up.
And period accounts
of that explosion
say that the explosion could
be heard 100 kilometers away.
So you could
practically be in Rome
and hear the sound of
this colossal boom.
The colossal mountain now
is kind of like a big mouth
waiting to erupt again,
like these bells.
The mouths the bells were
all facing the ceiling.
So this became kind
of an idea that I
began to play with and work
with in the piece, this idea
of a kind of silent tongue.
As the piece evolved--
and I'll play you
maybe five minutes of a kind of
finished version of the piece,
of a radio edit of the
peace, a short version.
I wanted to also process
not just bells, but voice.
And I asked the host
if they could find me
a singer who lived
on Mount Vesuvius.
And they said, oh, yeah,
we've got a singer for you.
So they found a singer.
And it was great.
She was in this metal band.
And she told me her my favorite
singer was Diamanda Galas.
I don't know if you
know Diamanda Galas,
but she is a very kind of
eccentric, powerful force
of a vocalist.
So she came with some
people from her band
to the place where
I was staying.
I recorded her voice.
And I began to also play around
with time stretching her voice.
Kind of moving forward to
the final stage of the work,
because there were several
versions of this piece.
There was a piece for the
opening with a dancer.
There were a couple concerts.
I liked it enough that I
use it concerts a few times.
I'll actually play parts
of this on Wednesday night.
But I also had this
experience where
I was in China for the
first time, in Beijing.
And I gave a concert.
Somebody came up to
me after the concert
and was really
interested in this piece.
Or actually was interested
in a piece I played.
So a conversation began.
And it turned out
the person who had
come to talk to me after the
concert was a singer trained
in kind of Peking
opera style, so
very traditional Chinese music.
Does anybody know
Chinese music here?
I really don't.
I've just been to China and
know some Chinese musicians.
So in any case, I
said, OK, would you
be interested in
singing a piece?
And she said sure.
I said, here's an MP3.
Come tomorrow night
at five o'clock.
We have a sound check.
We'll see how this goes.
So let me find a
version of this,
so kind of a later generation
of this piece I played you
earlier with the bells,
I'll just play an excerpt.
You'll hear three things
which are new here.
One is there's a sound of a
singer from Napoli singing not
Italian syllables, just kind
of making up her syllables.
And then on top of that there's
also a Chinese vocalist.
So this kind of became this
sort of vocal time collage that
kept on getting elaborated on
in the course of a few projects.
And I'm playing
saxophone as well.
And the bells are kind
of fading out here.
Those are the bells.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'll stop that here.
I won't play all
of it because I'll
play the whole
thing on Wednesday.
So we'll hear the
whole thing then.
But that piece turned into
kind of a trio voices.
There's a saxophone.
There's this very time
stretched processed voice, which
is mostly based on this
Italian woman singing.
And there's an improvisation by
a person who does Peking opera,
but was interested in
doing electronic music
for the first time basically.
And so that piece kind
of took its course
through just interacting
with people that I found,
a choreographer, a
singer, a collector
who had interest in a
sculpture that he thought
might make a sound.
Actually nobody was a jazz
musician except for me.
So that's just an
example of a piece
I did in which these interests
I have kind of coalesce.
There's an interest in
working with artists outside
of music, choreographer.
There's interest in fine
art, working with a collector
to get his idea
for materials that
might be interesting
to play with sonically.
And I'm still
playing the saxophone
in a way which is not
completely unlike how
I play in a jazz setting.
Any questions,
comments thus far?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So did you get both
the singers first and then
decide whether [INAUDIBLE] and
how did you do your sax part?
Is that what came last?
NEIL LEONARD: Well in this
case it did come last.
There was a lot of
sound design work.
I guess for the premiere
that we did in Napoli-- I'm
not worried about
playing the sax.
I can play the sax for
40 minutes no problem.
I was concerned about having
enough electronic material,
enough of the sound collage.
So I invested a lot of time in
getting that happening first.
And that probably
took for the premiere,
I had and some
fragments of it made,
but there was a couple
weeks of work nonstop
on the electronic score.
And then probably two
days before the concert,
I began to play around
the saxophone and kind
of find where it fit in,
although I kind of intuitively
knew here's a place I
left for me to fit in.
Here's a place for me to fit in.
Other questions?
Yeah
AUDIENCE: What sort
of [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Vocal recordings?
I did one which I'll show
you, which is really--
I'll do a very
quick version of it.
I found out that a piece of
software that worked really
well, is a piece of
software that's free.
It's Windows and PC.
It's called Spear.
And I'll show you
one of the things.
I don't want to spend
too much time on it
because it's really fun.
It's a lot of fun.
But there it is.
This is a recording
of the trombonist
I'm playing with on Wednesday.
It's a solo trombone track.
And what the software's
going to do-- just
going to say yes
to the defaults.
It's going to do an
analysis of the sound.
And the analysis
takes the sound.
And it describes the sound.
Try and shrink this, zoom
out as far as possible.
It's freeware.
It's kind of clunky,
but it works.
So this file, let me see
if I can just play it.
[TROMBONE]
NEIL LEONARD: So
just a trombone.
Now, just a trombone-- you
really don't see everything
on the projector, but that's OK.
These are frequencies from
zero Hertz up 8,500 Hertz.
And this, of course, is
a timeline over here.
And it deconstructs the sound
into a plot of sine waves.
So without really
getting too far into it,
let me just do one
thing to convince you
that it's really doing that.
So we'll go over here.
And I'm going to take
some of these sine waves.
I'm going to select them just
by control clicking on them.
And I'll just grab some of them.
There they are.
And now I'll go to
New from Select.
We'll make a new
file from selection.
And there's only the
sine waves I selected.
Let's play those and
see what it sounds like.
[SOUNDS]
NEIL LEONARD: Those are
sounds that are in there.
Now, there happen to be hundreds
of sine waves at a given
moment.
What we just heard is this.
[TROMBONE]
NEIL LEONARD: If we grab
some more sine waves--
actually I'll do it like this.
What's the first
letter of your name?
AUDIENCE: V.
NEIL LEONARD: OK, we'll
make a V. Not a great V,
you could do better.
And I can select them that way
just to have fun with this.
And there we go.
And we can play this.
[SOUNDS]
NEIL LEONARD: You can probably
see it on my laptop better.
The greys show up
better on this.
But do you get the idea?
That sound, the sound
of the trombone,
the trombone performance,
is deconstructed
into a series of sine waves.
If we play them all, we hear
the whole trombone performance.
If we take out
certain ones, then it
sounds like a filtered trombone.
Now, here's one of the
things I did quite a bit,
in terms of, what did
you do with voice.
And what was the
question you asked me?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, what sort
of things did you play?
NEIL LEONARD: OK, here's one.
[TROMBONE]
NEIL LEONARD: Let's take that.
Let's go right there where I
think he kind of changes a note
and gets a bit more complicated.
I want to time stretch it.
So I'm going to say
Transform, Time Stretch.
And I'm going to make it four
times longer, times four.
So.
[TROMBONE]
NEIL LEONARD: So you can also
hear him move from one note
to another.
All of a sudden it
doesn't sound so clean.
He's a very articulate player.
But all of a sudden
you get this moment
of transition, which
is pretty cool.
In fact, if I thought that I
really wanted more of that,
I'll Time Stretch the same
thing again times four.
What do we get now?
[TROMBONE]
NEIL LEONARD: It's
like a tri tone.
It's a pretty difficult
to play and you kind of
get some of that tension
of him playing it.
There are many different
ways to time stretch.
They all have artifacts.
None of them are perfect.
But some of the
artifacts I like.
So some ways of
stretching it are useful.
And other ways just sound bad.
So there was quite a
bit of time stretching.
But I guess that piece is
not really that extravagant.
I also sort of
collaged at this level.
So, for example, we can make a
collage of just these partials.
We can take these lines and
treat it like a drawing,
and rearrange where
the lines are.
So, in fact, I
think I can, again,
without going too far in
this, I can offset this time.
And I'll push all
that stuff over here.
Now, it's probably
going to be a mess
because you can hear
two notes at a time.
Or we're going to see
what you can here.
[TROMBONE]
NEIL LEONARD: So all this is
to say that, like in Photoshop,
you have this sort of
incredible facility
for rearranging the
pixels in an image.
This is like dealing with
sound at the pixel level.
Every component
sine wave of sound
can be stretched independently,
shrunk independently,
transposed.
In face, we could take some
of these sounds-- actually
I won't go any further because
I'll just go on and on.
And none of this will be what
we really want to listen to.
But you get the idea.
So I used off the shelf
software you pay for.
I used freeware, spent
hours, and hours,
and hours in that play,
research, failure,
mode of just trying
more stuff out.
Let me just see if I begin to
experiment, what will I get?
How are we doing for time?
We're probably OK.
I guess where George Martin
and The Beatles were, is
they did this by
tape manipulation,
as you had pointed
us to earlier.
And now, of course,
nobody's using tape.
It's expensive.
It's not as flexible.
It has a particular
sound that people love.
But nobody's using it.
I work at Berkeley.
There's a Department of
production engineering
which is like the tape tribe.
They still worship
reel-to-reel reel tape decks.
They grew up with
reel-to-reel tape decks.
They learned their craft
with reel-to-reel tape decks.
They edited Bruce
Springsteen's recordings
on reel-to-reel tape decks.
They think it has
to be understood.
But they can't use it
either because it's
big, and expensive, and slow.
And production has
to be cheap and fast.
So we're doing it
in the computer now.
But quite a bit of
this is being done.
Other than the time
stretching, a lot of that work
was not that extravagant.
And what I wanted to do was
take the phrases of that singer
and really kind of
distort her lines in time.
So when she sang, some lines
were held for a very long time.
Some syllables went at
the natural sung rate.
So they appeared
normal, so to speak.
But I'll also
point out something
that Mark and I talked
about on the telephone
when we were
discussing this class
and your assignment, which
is the next we'll talk about,
is that this semester I hosted
a composer named Hans Tutschku.
Hans Tutschku is the director
of the computer music
program at Harvard.
And if you ever get
a chance, there's
probably a concert coming up
probably at the end of April.
And he does concerts with what
he calls the hydra system.
The hydra system is a
collection of 40 speakers.
And you sit inside
the 40 speakers.
And it's a little bit like going
to a cathedral, where there's
like a dome, and the dome
has a painting on it.
If you ever go to the
Vatican, for example, there's
this beautiful dome,
with this ring,
with this text which
is really important.
And it's just a
great experience.
It's an installation.
It's a work of art.
The dome is a work of art.
This is the sonic dome.
And there are three
rings of speaker.
One's at ear level.
One kind of maybe six
feet above ear level,
and like 12 feet
above ear level.
And the rings the rings
go really wide, smaller,
and smallest.
So he came to Berkeley.
And the students
were all excited.
Here's this guy from Harvard.
He's got to be important.
And he uses 40 speakers.
So he's got to be more
sophisticated than us.
He knows things we don't know.
And the fascinating thing was he
showed us these pieces he made,
which were fantastic
piece of music.
He made them like--
I'm recording
this lecture on this little
Sony handheld recorder.
it's not that expensive.
He made all his recordings
with a little Zoom
handheld recorder, like $400.
And he was saying one of things
he likes to do is wave it.
So if he's playing
an antique piano,
which is all out of tune.
And he's recording the sound.
He'll move, he'll sweep,
like a visual artist
would move a camera.
If a visual artist is going
to shoot a video of a rock,
they're probably not going
to put the video on a tripod
to shoot the rock.
I mean, there's a
pretty good chance
they'll want to move to show us
different aspects of this rock.
Well, this is what Hans
loves to do with microphones,
move them across the surface.
Because his argument
is if you have a gone,
and you hit the gong, and
you move it by your ear,
the gong sounds one way
if it's 30 feet away,
one way if it's 10 feet away,
and one way it it's very soft
and you're right next to it.
Those are three completely
different sounds.
They're all gong.
But the details you get
are radically different.
So one thing I want
to point out is
that the selection
of the materials
is a major part of the work.
And one of the things Hans said,
which I also had been doing,
but I'd never really thought
about in quite the way he
was discussing it, was he only
uses sounds he records himself.
And he's been doing this
for a long time, decades.
And so he has all
kinds of sounds
he's made all over the world.
But the important thing
about all the sounds
is that he has a
memory of recording
each one, of choosing
to record each one.
So of these thousands
of sounds he might have,
he has a visceral
experience that's
associated with every sound.
So those bells I recorded,
are bells I recorded.
And I know the
weight of the bell.
I know the color of the bell.
I know where it
was in the Earth.
I remember what it was like
to put the mic on there.
I remember how hot
it was that day.
I remember how we kind
of hit them with hammers,
did all kinds of things to
try to get a sound out of them
because they weren't free
standing bells really
made to be struck.
Same with the vocalist, I
remember hearing this vocalist,
and we had a discussion
about getting something
that would work in this piece.
So all those memories are
valuable when you go back
to your material
because otherwise it's
just a sound file.
Like every other sound file,
maybe I like it, maybe I don't.
But because you have been
involved in physically
recording and
capturing that sound,
it's as if it was in your hands.
You have a kind of
tactile relation
to the sound that you
wouldn't have otherwise.
Now here's what I'm going
to ask you guys to do.
So I understand you've
worked not only with Mark,
but you've work with
my colleague Tom Hall.
And I'm actually playing a
concert with Tom Hall on Sunday
at a place called The
Outpost with a bassist named
Jamaaladeen Tacuma, who
is known for his work
with Ornette Coleman,
very good bassist.
Mark has also told
me that you work
in pairs, or sometimes
groups of three.
And with your pair,
I'm going to ask
you to make a
collaborative improvisation
with audio recordings.
And your goal is to, with
your partner or partners,
create small sound
library to utilize
in a two to three
minute improvisation.
And you're going to prepare
a performance that integrates
the playback of
some of the sounds
you record in this performance.
So let me ask you one thing.
How do you like to improvise?
And how do you
improvise in this class?
Is it more along the lines
of free improvisation?
Are people improvising with
a chord, or with a tonic,
or is it all of the above?
PROFESSOR: We've done
modal improvisation.
We've done graphic notation,
like Cage's notations.
We've created our own scripts
for that, and then done that.
We've done a lot of free.
We've done a lot of with
small little parameters.
Indian concepts
of Phil Scarf too.
NEIL LEONARD: So all
of those are fine.
Any of the approaches
to improvisation
that you have been
working with this semester
that you want to use for the
improvisation you do for me
next week, or I'll do with
you next week, is welcome.
It's going to be much more
interesting for all of us
if you're doing something
which you like to do so.
And I don't know
you that well so I
don't want to tell you what
to do with the improvisation
except I want you to use
whatever technology you have
at your disposal, which might
be your iPhone-- probably
everybody has a phone
that can record audio.
It could be a phone.
It could be an iPad.
It could be a portable
recording device.
And I want you to make
a collection of sounds.
Say how many, it could be four.
It could be 10.
And I want you to use
this original material
as source material for
this improvisation.
So it can be valuable
to go to the internet,
and find an audio archive, and
get audio, and do a piece based
on what you found
on the Internet.
And I can think of some
really cool examples.
But I'm going to encourage
you not to do that.
So I actually want you
to think about the sounds
that-- you don't have to leave
where you live, where you work,
where you study.
Within this part of the
world that you travel in,
you can get the sounds there.
So plan a recording in a
location that you frequent
daily, your walk to school,
your apartment, your job.
The idea is to listen
to your environment
and discover new details that
help divert the audience's
attention from the
typical mode of listening
to everyday sounds.
So when you think of
the role of audio,
of using audio recordings,
in improvisation,
you get a few things.
One is you get what
Luciano Berio said
is we open the sound
pallet up to everything.
Now, you could prepare
your guitar, for example.
If you play acoustic guitar, or
cello, or piano, or whatever,
you could prepare your guitar.
Do you know that is to prepare
your guitar in the John Cage
sense?
In the John Cage,
preparing a piano
meant like putting
bolts in the strengths.
I'm not going to encourage you
to do that with this piano.
But people put paper clips,
erasers, and screws and stuff
in the piano.
And it changed
the way it sounds.
There's a beautiful Cage
recording of prepared piano.
It makes it sound kind
of like a gamelan.
You could prepare
your instrument.
As long as you're
making the recording,
I'm probably not going to
say, you can't do that.
You could record
sounds of cars whizzing
by you on Memorial Drive.
But one of the things
which I didn't really
put in writing here, but
I think is important,
is if you can find either
one keynote sound, or one
idea about sound, that you'd
like to play with, it might
be-- you might get
more out of that then
recording like 15
completely different sounds.
If you want to record 15
completely different sounds,
I'm not going to stop you, but
I'm actually encourage you to--
Think of it this way.
If you had a play, if we were
doing theater for next week,
and we said, let's make a play.
And there are going
to be five actors.
The first actor is probably
not going to come on the scene
and then never come back again.
They're probably not going
to just say one thing
and then leave.
Although, now that I say this,
I can think of some examples
where that happens.
In fact, I went to go see
Mahler's Third at the BSO.
And there's a singer who
sang literally five lines.
And she came out halfway.
This is 100 minute symphony.
She came out halfway through,
sang literally five lines,
and stood on the stage
for the rest of the time.
It was really weird.
It was a great piece of music.
But it was weird.
But the point is this, if
you're thinking prepared guitar,
or if you're thinking of the
sound of opening and closing
windows in your
apartment, or whatever
it is that you're
interested in, what does it
sound like in the quad, or
between the buildings here?
You get sort of a theme and
variation potential, or a kind
of multiple perspective feature
in your piece, if you will,
if you have more than one
recording of a certain thing.
So let me ask you.
I'm just going to pick
your brains right now.
If you were to choose
something to record
to include in an
improvisation-- I
don't want your
final answer now.
But I'm just going to
pick on all of you guys
just to kind of get
the conversation going.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: James.
PROFESSOR: James,
so what would you
do if you had to pick right now?
AUDIENCE: I think
the sounds of riding
the bus would be interesting,
the doors opening and closing,
or stop requests.
I feel like you could play a lot
with all the different sounds
involved.
PROFESSOR: For sure,
and it would also
have the built in connotation
of the piece's emotion.
The piece is stopping.
The piece is starting.
The motion of the
piece is stopping.
The motion is starting.
I had a teacher who when I went
back to my master's degree,
a really wonderful composer
named Bob Brookmeyer.
And he said music is motion.
Anything you do to impede the
motion has to be questioned.
It doesn't mean to you
can't impede the motion.
But think twice if you're
going to impede the motion.
Well, this is a
piece about a bus.
Or a piece that's including
sounds from the bus,
so that's kind of
like a built in idea.
The bus has stops.
Good.
Perfect.
Your name again?
AUDIENCE: Vineet.
The sounds of an elevator.
NEIL LEONARD:
Elevator, sure, good.
And there must be
different elevators
in different places on campus.
Hopefully old, clunky ones.
And ones that are not
so old and clunky.
When I got this new
recorder, that's
the first thing I think
I recorded was elevator.
I was in a hotel that made
a really strange sound.
So I figured, OK,
I've got to grab this.
And I'll see if I make
something out of it?
What is your name?
AUDIENCE: Sarah, I think
I'd do my roommate cooking.
NEIL LEONARD: Roommate
cooking, great, good.
The piece is cooking.
There's kitchen, lots of stuff.
There is a teacher
at Berkeley who
has his students do a piece.
I think the piece
is in their kitchen.
It's found sound in the kitchen.
There's so many things
to rattle, and shake,
and make stuff out of, good.
And, again, what we're
thinking of doing is
we're not making a grand opus.
We're making a piece that's
two or three minutes long.
So you definitely have a few
minutes of sound from cooking.
What is your name?
AUDIENCE: Jacob.
I was thinking various
machines around a dorm,
so washing machine,
microwave, people typing.
NEIL LEONARD: Good.
That would be fine.
Tons of automation, which is
a really interesting topic.
When I first got
into computers, one
of the things that they
seem to offer to music,
which was a big question
mark, was automation.
You can automate a musical
process with a computer.
If you're writing software,
if you're creating software,
you can describe a process
of generating notes or sounds
and have it do that.
So automation sounds, fine.
So all of these four ideas
that we just touched on
are exactly what I was
kind of hoping to get to,
where you have an idea of
something you can play with.
These are all fine.
Your name is in
the orange shirt?
AUDIENCE: Ben.
NEIL LEONARD: Ben?
What do you think
would you record?
AUDIENCE: I was thinking maybe
the sounds of the locker room,
which the loudest of
which are probably
people slamming their lockers.
NEIL LEONARD: Yeah, good.
Percussion piece.
PROFESSOR: I want to clarify
something for myself and maybe
for others.
So when we've had these
other assignments,
I've called them
design assignments.
And that's what we talked about.
So should we be thinking about
how we design the framework?
In other words,
you had a framework
with your certain
phases, certain segments.
Should we be thinking that way?
NEIL LEONARD:
Absolutely, and we want
to think about how
to use these sounds.
So before we get to
framework, let just say,
in terms of the playback
of these sounds,
it's kind of flexible.
I mean, a simple thing
that you could do
is you could make a playlist in
iTunes of sounds you've created
and play with this playlist.
You also probably want to
make some sound of silence.
The sound might be more
effective if you're not
hearing your recorded
sounds all the time,
but you're hearing the
sounds some of the time.
So you don't have to inundate
us with recorded sound.
It could be very, very poetic.
It might just be that a few
moments of recorded sound
add another dimension
to improvisation.
So that would be the simplest
way to use the sounds.
Is everybody OK with that?
I mean, everybody has iTunes.
So you could do it that way.
Everybody can record a sound
which is basically really,
really quiet or
silent, so to speak.
So you can also put in blocks.
You can space out silence.
That kind of would
be a composition.
The other way to think of
this would be-- and then
let's make sure we have time
to talk a little bit more
about context-- is when
you're working in pairs,
one person could use the iPhone,
or the computer, or the iPad.
And the other person could play.
So the two of you don't have
to improvise simultaneously.
One person could be more
working the computer.
And one person could
do the playing.
So, for example, if--
what's your name?
AUDIENCE: Forest.
NEIL LEONARD: And what
instrument is that?
Is that yours?
AUDIENCE: No, I play the piano.
NEIL LEONARD: So
Forest, for example,
who would your partner be?
AUDIENCE: Austin.
NEIL LEONARD: Austin, OK,
good, so if Forest and Austin
did a piece, and Forest is
playing piano and improvising,
and Austin is
working the computer,
one thing you could
do, Austin, is
you could trigger the
sounds at your discretion
in a spontaneous way.
You could improvise.
It won't be like
playing the piano
where there's a whole
lot of finger motion.
But you could choose in
relation to Forest's performance
when to trigger the sounds.
So you're not triggering
them all at once.
You're not triggering them in a
sequence that's predetermined.
You could trigger
them as you go.
So does that makes sense?
So I think in order for this
to be successful-- in order
for the use of the
recorded playback of sound
to be more robust and to
give you more flexibility,
it probably make sense,
unless you think otherwise
and have a difference scheme,
but my first suggestion
would be to have one
person improvising
with these sound files
and another person
improvising on the
traditional instrument.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: In your
performances, is it
usually balanced like that?
Where one person is operating
some part of the electronics?
The electronics are
also improvised?
Or it more just
straight recording.
NEIL LEONARD: It's a
very good question.
Because I only have two hands,
and the saxophone, really,
you can't do it with one hand.
Piano, you could probably
pull it off a little better.
But I'm usually doing three
things, playing the saxophone,
doing live audio processing of
the saxophone, which we didn't
touch on, which I don't think
we'll have time to today,
but we could touch
on it next time.
And then playing
back sound files.
So at certain times, I tried to
improvise everything, and write
software to
improvise everything.
And I've sort of moved
away from that approach
in favor of building these sound
collages which I know very well
and perform with.
But I do live sax processing
which is improvised.
And that's what I'll
do on Wednesday.
But I wan to go
back to the issue
that Mark raises about
a formal structure.
And I'm going to ask you to
help with this as well because I
didn't come today with a
very exact formal structure.
Or really I didn't come
with a formal structure.
So one of the things
that comes to mind
is-- and actually
maybe Mark you should
help with the
brainstorming of this.
But one of the things
that does come to mind
is do the sounds you record
suggest any kind of structure?
So, for example, if you're
thinking locker room,
if I go to the gym, I
have a combination lock.
I don't how much
noise that makes.
It's probably pretty quiet.
But the bang of the lockers.
What do you do with the
banging of the lockers?
They can be kind of cacophonous,
as they sort of are.
They don't really
kind of open and close
with any kind of logic.
If I go to the gym at 6 o'clock,
and a lot of people are there,
there's a lot of opening
and closing of doors.
But because you're
recording, potentially you
could trigger things live, who
would your partner be in this?
Who was your last partner
in an improv project?
AUDIENCE: James
NEIL LEONARD: And James is you?
So if you did this
with James, James
could do something which is
not typical of a locker room,
where things are opening
and closing periodically.
So you're making a rhythm
out of these lockers.
I do want to mention
something about that.
But I want to talk
about a slamming door
piece, or a banging piece that
maybe I can bring next time
and play for you.
But maybe it's a binary form.
One part is more free.
And the banging feels
like less-- just
seems a little random.
And another other part
seems decisively not random.
Mark, what do you think?
What have they done with form
that would be applicable here?
PROFESSOR: I think we've
done a lot of these things.
So I would say leave it
up to people's ideas.
NEIL LEONARD: OK, that's fine.
I have the impression
anything you've
thought about with form
already probably is still--
could be applicable here.
PROFESSOR: And we
could apply things.
I think what I would say is
if you could think of a way
to have a beginning
and an ending,
and maybe a middle
marker of some sort.
If that makes sense.
NEIL LEONARD: Good, good.
I do want to say one thing
about noise and banging doors.
I just want to say
a couple that does
sound art, Janet Cardiff and
George Miller is her partner.
And Janet Cardiff just did
a piece in a New York armory
in the last 12 months.
But she's famous for
making these pieces where
they were like audio walks,
where you would headphones on.
And it would be like she
was on the walk with you.
And she would tell
you where to go.
There was a Central Park one.
And as you're walking with
this person who's not there,
it's like a disembodied voice,
she begins to tell you a story.
And you're getting kind of
wrapped up in the story.
And the next thing, a
helicopter flies right by you.
And you turn around,
and it's not there.
So it's a kind of a
talk kind of reshapes
your audio experience
on a specific
walk that she's designed it for.
So, again, a site-specific
piece of art.
But she and George
Miller were invited
to do a piece at the
Eastern State Penitentiary
in Pennsylvania, which
is in Philadelphia.
It's a penitentiary
which is infamous
for, among other
things, it was maybe
the first penitentiary
in the United States
where they had
this big experiment
in solitary confinement.
So one of the wings, or
maybe in all of the wings,
prisoners were isolated
in cells by themselves
with only a Bible with the idea
that if they were by themselves
with a Bible they
would have nothing
to do but reform themselves.
And I think that it did not
become the model for reform.
But they now commission
artworks in the Eastern State
Penitentiary.
And so what they did is they
made these kind of robots--
I won't call them robots--
but these beaters that
were motorized.
And they were maybe
in this one corridor
there were like 162
cell blocks, both sides
of the corridor, first
and second floor.
And they had at least
one of these beaters
in every one of
these cell blocks.
Now, this corridor had
not been renovated.
It was still like totally
dilapidated, paint
chipping all over the
place, water damage.
But they never cleaned it out.
So there was still
some furniture,
which means like beds,
bed pans, whatever it as.
So they put beaters
in every cell block.
And they controlled them.
They were controlled
by computer.
And they did exactly
what I was saying,
which is where I
got the idea, is
they made this 16 minute score.
And they did it with a computer.
And they did it in a sequence.
They did it actually
in the same one
I'm using now, Logic, and
the piano roll notation.
And everyone little
note in the piano roll
was a different hammer
in a different cell.
So in some parts
of the recording.
It's very pointalistic.
You would hear a sound
from one cell, then
something from the other
side of the corridor.
There's kind of a
race section where
they're all pounding
out a rhythm.
But they're kind
of different sounds
that-- I mean, you can only
imagine what the inmates would
have thought if
whatever it would be,
really 150 years later.
This is long-- this is
like totally over, pretty
horrible place.
But it was a banging piece.
Lockers bang.
So it was a piece that
was all about banging,
banging in a corridor, kind
of almost like a prison riot
kind of vibe from the
recording I've heard of it.
I didn't actually see the piece.
But they had a structure too.
And part of the structure
was have a rave.
So there was kind
of a beat, or I
don't know if you could call
it a recognizable groove.
But there was sort of
like a periodic thumping
happening at one
part of the piece.
Other parts were more
noisy and pointalistic.
So given that I don't know
what you're going to record,
and I also don't want to
make the piece for you,
I'm kind of open to form.
But I would say this, open
to your ideas about form.
But be prepared to tell us why
you recorded these sounds, what
was attractive about recording
the sounds, what it was
like after you recorded them
because everything's different
after you record it.
The classic example
are gunshots.
You think a gunshot
would be powerful.
But when they made
the film Terminator,
they took Howitzer's, and
cannons, and bazookas,
and they put them all together
to make these guns that Arnold
Schwarzenegger would shoot to
make them sound like comic book
big, larger than life.
But guns don't sound
larger than life.
They sound smaller than
life, just like a little pop.
In Hollywood, there
is a job in Hollywood,
should you be interested,
in making guns sound big.
Many of my students
go and do that stuff.
So why did you want
to record these?
What was your initial thought
about recording these sounds?
Like, the kitchen, my
roommate makes all this,
boiling, there's sauteing,
there's stuff coming out
of the toaster, there's
water boiling, all that.
And that seemed like
it's a pallet which
could be interesting.
Whatever your
reason is, whatever
your experience is after.
And then also going back to
what mark suggested, how did you
think about
organizing the sound?
Because I'm not so much
interested in right or wrong,
but what were your
thoughts about putting
this stuff together?
Did you have a thought
before you improvised
about how to arrange
this improvisation
with your partner?
Did you guys just
plunge into it?
If you had a thought about
how to use it, with the bus,
does it begin with
starting the bus?
Does it end with
the bus stopping?
It doesn't have to.
But that would be
another valuable part
of your experience to
bring to the discourse.
Once you had those
sounds, how did you
go from there to
finishing a piece?
So as you see with me,
it's like, I come up
with some cool sounds.
I record some
elevators, some bells.
And sometimes I just start
messing with the stuff.
But at some point, it's
actually got to finish a piece.
So once I start to set
out to make a piece,
then typically I'm beginning
to think of what kind of shape
should the piece have?
I have a degree in
music composition
so I kind of neurotically
have to deal with it that way.
You don't have to.
And I think any way you
deal with it can potentially
be successful.
But one of the things I learned
from a teacher I had was
that the first thing you do
when you write a piece of music
is you decide the duration.
The second you can do is can
could think about the form.
And when you're thinking about
the form, the order in which
stuff's going to happen,
you're actually preparing,
if you call this
composition, you're
actually composing music
without hearing a sound.
I could think start
soft, end loud.
I could think, start
fast, end slow.
And those are really
compositional decisions
which I can make
without making a sound.
I can think of only
lockers opening
at the beginning, only
lockers closing at the end.
That's a compositional decision.
That came from George Russell.
You can compose.
Or, because this is a
class in improvisation,
you can create sonic ideas
without making a sound.
And my neurosis as a composer
and as a lifelong student
of composition, is I want to
use that approach, at least
to some level.
Not in everything
I do, but I'm often
trying to think about what are
some ideas about these pieces
before I roll up my sleeves
and start making stuff?
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry.
We're going to have to call
time because we have to leave.
NEIL LEONARD: I think
that's a good place to stop.
PROFESSOR: Thank you very much.
I just have one
practical question.
We should think about how
we're going to present these
because we're going
to wind up with 16.
Does that mean
we're going to have
six computers with individual
sound files or what?
NEIL LEONARD: I think
so, because it's probably
easiest for you
just to set it up
on your phone, or your
iPad, or your computer,
and plug them in here.
The only thing
about that is this
seemed to behave better when
video is plugged in as well.
But maybe we can just
plug video into my machine
and swap in and out of
this cable if need be.
PROFESSOR: OK, so in
each team, one person
should bring some device.
Is that OK?
Great.
Assignment for Wednesday,
I got inspired.
I'm improvising.
We're going to bring
our instruments.
I want you to think between now
and then of at least one sound
that is not a conventional
sound on your instrument.
If you can think
of two or three,
that's great, but at
least one sound that
not conventional
to your instrument.
OK?